[Applause]
swimming is so stupid can we just talk
about how stupid swimming Jaime is the
best for him to exercise but is it don't
work yeah it is
hey is it you know who swims every day
at the local YMCA who Larry legend your
dad he cut that [ __ ] out cuz a stupid
bro that was the first thing my dad
forgot what he all sad exactly if I'd
become the best swimmer I can be and
then I just want to be [ __ ] whining
all the time yeah get out of here dude
now my dad did swim that's a fact but he
also had like four knee surgeries so is
the only way that you could do it he
used to be a marathon runner and he
would do that she had army boots like a
[ __ ] boxer that's what boxer used to
run it he got the illest bunions and the
craziest nails ever really bad don't
ever do that death so he had to he was
forced to swim he didn't want to try but
like the swimming thing can we get rid
of it can we get it out of the Olympics
what the hell is he thinking what do you
mean in combat boots
that's what boxers used to James doing
marathons yo they realize they learn
aisles what do you mean a boxer runs
like eight miles he don't run 26 or
whatever it is son Larry Schultz ain't
no [ __ ] Larry Schultz out here dick and
down girls you know I'm saying before
all before my mom who's picking down
these girls but dicks down doing it with
the fatty
he had that fatty broke stop when I'm
full of it full pubic hair too full of
what what what fat dick is stuffing fat
dick in there dude that's how these work
is cream I'll go that's how you could
tell there's double standards cuz I want
my dad to get all the [ __ ] before my
mom and if my mama's out her [ __ ]
dues I'm like you hold [ __ ] is wrong
with you
right save your puss for my dad come out
of
is crazy but if girls are being [ __ ]
up to my dad nah you just wished a
double standard mid double standard no
like if girls were disrespecting my dad
by not giving him [ __ ] back in the day
that's [ __ ] up like that's super foul
I think it's because you look at your
mom like that's your first house you
know I mean you don't want to be lived
in so yeah if some guys like
disrespecting it you're like oh man it's
like someone's like ruining your
apartment yeah there's like when your
school gets knocked down it's like damn
that was mine yeah bro no [ __ ] I
remember my dad [ __ ] my mom when I
was in my mom come on no dead serious
dog dead serious I remember I was
bobbing weaving like Mayweather and that
[ __ ] shoulder roll in a box so yeah
maybe I think he was I think he would
deep stroke and I have to get away from
it and I have to dip slip under Jerome
said sometimes I punch back you throw
jabs say what throw jab hook throw jabs
once I remember I got my whole fist
stuck in his urethra
I remember that [ __ ] and then he would
cool you down say yeah one time he threw
a Hadouken all over me that [ __ ] was wet
I used to bust his side in here dog I'm
in here it's a flood he was at least two
times the percent is the first umbrella
though that [ __ ] is a perfect bike dude
can it cover you had a shield all time
yeah get out of here were never in any
real danger I think I had a drop-top
placenta dog [ __ ] face in his
shoulder son I think he might have broke
my placenta
oh maybe yeah maybe it's just like
wearing 4-ounce mitts a release
this far inland you still gonna field
okay so the sperm doesn't touch you no
matter what the placenta protects
hundred percent it protects yeah yeah
real talk yeah I remember one time I try
to get him with that umbilical cord I
try to chuckle and he saw it coming just
snuck that dick right out of there real
quick alright well I I can say that made
words that
[Music]
[Applause]